There I am. We're going to go ahead and get started.
Thanks for making the long trek all the way down here.
I need a little scooter, I think, to get down here.
But I'm really excited to be chairing this session again this year.
It's really nice to see the AACR commit to the understanding of the
metabolic regulation of the immune system.
This is something, of course, that is still a fairly new field.
It really brought about by the study of cancer metabolism and
really appreciating now the importance of being
able to metabolically fuel your immune system.
So we have two awesome presenters plus me, you're going to have to
listen, drone on, that we're going to be talking about
various aspects of the immune system and cancer.
I'd like you to go ahead and scan this QR code that's on the slide.
I don't know where it takes us, but please go ahead and scan that QR code.
That's
an important piece of what we're going to do.
It's going to be on for about 20 or 30 seconds before we have our first speaker
today.
So go ahead and
do that QR code thing.
What is it for?
What is it for? I don't even know what it's for.
Q&A.
Q&A. All right, so you can put the Q&A in.
I'll be monitoring it online, so if you are on the virtual platform, I will be
monitoring that online. We're going to have three talks.
We'll have questions after each one, and if we have time at the end, we'll do a
panel discussion.
Okay, great. So with that, I'm going to first invite up our first
speaker, Dr Owen Sansom, who's going to come talk to us about various aspects of
modeling immune metabolism and cancer. Thanks.
Oops. Thank you very much for the invite from the panel.
And
as we're just getting into the immune metabolism field, I'll be giving you a bit of
an overview of some of the work that we're sort of ongoing and started in this
space. So,
I thought I'd start to really tell you about how we got into
really sort of working and trying to look more deeply at
metabolism.
And really this came apart as part of one of CRUK's grand challenges.
And our aim, which is now finished, and the aim about sort of
eight, nine years ago when this started, was really to see whether we could go
beyond genetics and start mapping metabolites in
vivo and seeing whether we could characterize tumors by their metabolic
phenotypes rather than just the genetics or the transcription.
And I guess one of the things that have really changed since we started that has
been the sort of spatial revolution that we can now do spatial
transcriptomics.
And so this was really our attempt to really see whether we could really
understand. And so,
the metabolism work was all driven in collaboration with the National Physics
Laboratory and Josephine Bunch. We had really great interactions from industry, and
we remain working very closely with AstraZeneca, and particularly Richard Goodwin
and Simon Barry.
And there was a number of us that came, and our role really within this was to
really drive the sort of the models and work out whether we could really
start understanding our models in terms of the metabolism.
And so really we had three key questions that we wanted to ask, and
really whether we could map the metabolic network of tumors,
both from the microenvironment, but also correlate that with transcriptional
processes. Can we think about segmenting cancers
by the metabolic phenotypes? We're very keen of doing things by
molecular subtypes. And thirdly, given that we are
now in a really exciting era where we can target
tumor oncogenes that drive metabolism within tumor cells, what are the downstream
consequences when you start drugging
the tumors to see what is the consequence then on the immune microenvironment?
And I'll give you a few stories today just around of how
we got on.
What was interesting is that we wanted to look at metabolism at all levels,
from very high throughput approaches such as the i-Knife, where you
can sort of just quickly do metabolite profiles, all the way
through to sort of really single cell level where you put
probes in and able to see it. But today I'm going to talk to you mainly around the
work we did with DESI.
And this gives you a resolution where you can see regions of interest, but not
quite the single cell.
And of course, the reason we did this is that we really felt that we wanted to go
away from disruptive metabolomics into spatially
resolved tissue metabolomics.
We've developed a panel now of
metabolites that we're very happy that we can see by DESI.
It was reproduced across three different sites,
and we've published protocols of how we do this.
But I guess in terms of immuno metabolism, as we said, we're very interested in
what the cancer cells produce, onco-metabolites,
those that might have paracrine effects such as lactate.
But we're also very interested in how that ultimately then affects the immune
system coming through that. So, as we
said, we've now developed a large
number of validated metabolites that we can see on tissue,
and I will talk you through some of these.
And many of these, when secreted, might have direct effects on the immune
systemAnd then obviously, I don't think you can speak at this
meeting really without mentioning the excitement over KRAS inhibitors.
But just to tell you that KRAS inhibitors ironically seem to work much
worse in colorectal cancer than diseases such as pancreatic cancer
and lung cancers. So if we look at the effect,
this is ceritinib, if you look at colon in terms of primary responses, they're very
poor. And indeed, if we take even what we call very simple models, and this is an
APC with a KRAS G12C, give it a RAS inhibitor, it
really doesn't do anything. So again, we're very interested to see what do we
need to cooperate with RAS mutations.
And then just one thing as we're moving through colorectal cancer models,
just to highlight, as a field, we've very much been
focused on looking how the plasticity of the normal
intestine is really recapitulated within our tumors.
So we have these normal stem cells, which are
LGR5 positive, which are highly proliferative,
that normally repopulate the epithelium.
But we also have, after damage, these regenerative
stem cells which come and replace the gut after
injury. And it's just important to note that Wnt signaling is very
important in driving these Wnt regenerative LGR5 stem cells.
But actually, MAP kinase and Yap-Taz are also very important in driving these
regenerative. And so therefore, we can sort of now classify our tumors
by the different percentages of these different epithelial populations.
And we now know that there's direct crosstalk between these two populations,
which means that there is almost a competition between them.
In terms of the other thing that sort of really took off in the colorectal field
over the last 20 years are really our models.
So,
we used to have very good models of adenoma and very good mouse models of small
intestinal adenoma, such as the Min mouse, and pretty average models of
late-stage carcinoma. And really we went through a revolution
back in 2015 when organoids were developed.
And so now that we have multiple organoids carrying all the mutations that
happen in colorectal, and if you make organoids from mice that
carry multiple mutations such as APC, KRAS, p53, TGF-beta, you
can transplant these back into immunocompetent hosts.
You can also take liver Mets and put them back into the liver.
So this allows us to really start really carefully looking at immunometabolism with
our whole suite of different organoid lines.
We've developed others of those, the sort of KRAS p53 Notch, which is
another metastatic model. And so therefore, for once, we have a really
excellent toolkit of a range of different
syngeneic lines that can really help
us look at crosstalk. And the other important thing is that we can also
now really look--
We have a huge range of human organoids.
So I guess where we started, it's very clicky this laptop,
was really to start off by doing DESI on some very simple models.
So here we just take APC and KRAS,
and looked at DESI. And then this is a
situation where you go into the mouse and you recombine in a patch of cells in a
colon. So you get one colon tumor out, it's an adenoma.
And then you can go in and obviously then look at the metabolism in the different
compartments. So we can look within the tumor, we can look within the stroma, and
we can also look at the normal adjacent.
And two very interesting things came out of this work.
So we can divide those populations very easily if
we look at-- So this is TSNE. You look at all the different
things that we see with the DESI, and as you can see, your tumor epithelium comes
out. We then have a very area of metabolite right
by the tumor interface, and there you can see the normal.
And then with MALDI, you can also see we can also define metabolites in different
positions and between the different populations.
Importantly, you can then go in and say, "What are our biggest differences?" And
so what was our surprise when we took an APC KRAS and compared it to the
APC?
The biggest difference was in the APC, we had a lot of glutamine
and not very much glucose. And so you
could really see that the APC KRAS was really massively depleted of glutamine
within the epithelium. Obviously, glutamine
is one of our major metabolites that we think for cell growth and proliferation.
But if you just ground up the tumor and did bulk, glutamine sat right in the
middle. So all the other metabolites in all the different other proportions of the
tumor was completely blanking our signal.
So we then went on and really wanted to work out what was happening with
glutamine. So therefore we could also then go in and just put the
mutation straight into the epithelium and nowhere else.
And what you could see is that, again, the glutamine was very much more
utilized by APC KRAS. We saw that a real change
in the amino acids, and we could label glucose all the way through.
And actually, in terms of functional requirement, if we went into organoids, what
you found was the APC doesn't need
glutamine to grow, but
the glutamine is not required, but your APC KRAS needed both.
And what was very interesting is we spent a lot of time in organoids then
trying to work out where glutamine was going.
And normally we think of glutamine moving into TCA cycle and
driving proliferation and growth.
So as we said, we can really show the glutamine in the APC, but not the APC
KRAS. But however,
in organoids, you needed glutamine to make alanine and alpha-ketoglutarate.
But in vivo, there was absolutely no functional consequences.
So what's very interesting is another major role for glutamine
is to be an antiporter
using this amino acid transporter, SLC7A5.
And what this does is this antiports glutamine but brings in essential
amino acids. And so therefore, this depletion of
glutamine that we're seeing from the APC KRAS actually wasn't its
role to move into TCA, it was this antiporter.
And so removing glutamine and pumping in the neutral amino
acids are very important. And one of the things to think about this is
SLC7A5, we found is highly upregulated in the APC
KRAS, but it's also highly upregulated under
energetic stress.And indeed you could see this because if you
went into the mouse now and deleted 7A5, you saw
accumulation, and again, this is using DESI again, of glutamine, glutamate, and
alanine.
And then functionally, if you then go and delete 7A5,
what you found was one of the biggest suppressions that we've seen in our
colorectal cancer models. And so therefore, this anti-porting, pushing glutamine
out and bringing it in was very important.
And mechanistically, this was in part by its ability to
be fundamentally important for the continued activation of
phosphorylation of S6. So we've learnt over the years that when you have APC
and K-RAS, rapamycin really is not a very good inhibitor.
So, this was a real important for the tumor to sustain its
proliferation. And indeed, we've done a whole range of other things now with
7A5, which really makes us think that when you have an APC K-RAS
7A5, it is very sensitive to treatment. This is with rapamycin.
And we can also do that with MAP kinase.
What is interesting is if you compare the loss of
7A5, one of our RAS dependent targets, to
RAS inhibition in the model, so if we treat APC and K-RAS' and treat
them with a RAS inhibitor,
there is no impacts in terms of tumor growth.
And indeed, what we're seeing is a very rapid epithelial cell switching.
So, we can put those marks into Xenium
panel so that we can say, "Well, where are our Wnt/Lgr5 cells?" And so if you
go in an APC tumor, they've got very high levels of Wnt cells.
In an APC K-RAS, as you can see, you turn on these
regenerative populations that take up most of the tumor.
Obviously, where you touch the
microbiome and where you touch the stroma, those
are not there. And then when you inhibit with the RAS inhibitor, all you do is
switch back to the APC fate, with purple remaining at the
interface with the microbiome. So what this tells us is that we have some very
interesting epithelial intrinsic resistance that allows cell switching.
So then that was for the anti-porter in
colon. We were very interested to see what was happening in pancreatic cancer.
So pancreatic cancer,
obviously a RAS related disease under heavily energetic stress.
And people have previously showed that SLC7A5 was very important in a
subtype of pancreatic cancer, which was the squamous subtype.
And so therefore you could define your pancreatic cancer
subtypes and cell lines, and you can see you've got classical and squamous.
And SLC7A5 was always very high in the squamous, which is
also called basal or high NC by some people.
And there's also this very interesting paper that came out in "Nature Cancer,"
which is really nice, by Holbrook and colleagues,
that said that actually if you go into pancreatic cancer cells, there is a
metabolic symbiosis. So cells are communicating with each other.
And you could find cells with high levels of
SLC7A5, which are self-sufficient and show these energetic.
But these are very important to spit out metabolites and
feed dependent ones. And so therefore, as well as having this
interaction with the stroma, there's metabolic crosstalk.
So we wanted, and as we say, as part of this hungry 7A5, and
actually if we go into pancreatic cancers in humans' mice, we see a very patchy
expression of 7A5.
So we wanted to say, well, if we delete 7A5 within an aggressive
pancreatic cancer model, would we or would we not see any impacts?
And this is, we used the sort of the gold standard in the field, the KPC mouse,
and if you delete 7A5, you really strikely
slow tumor genesis.
There was no impact on PanINs, and actually many of your mice developed
tumors that were not pancreatic.
And then if you go in and look at the subtypes, what you find is when you delete
7A5, the tumors are even more squamous,
and they really are not these classical.
And so therefore, what you're doing is really by altering metabolic
cooperation within the tumor, you're pushing tumors into a more
homogeneous state. And you could tell this.
This is ASNS, which is one of the markers of those
hungry cells, and you can see this is very patchy.
When you knock out 7A5, you ingest this massively,
and cells get stuck in this fate and find it very difficult to
grow. We also have an immune induction around these tumors
as well. So we see really big effects, and so I think it's a very
interesting thought when we start thinking about crosstalk
between epithelial cells.
And then to fun off, I'll finish with our work where we're really moving
much more into the immunometabolite field.
So we're very interested about how cells spread.
And there's been some very nice work that says that these sort of regenerative
cells are the ones that go to distant organs.
And then you then regrow your tumor and then turn on Lgr5
populations. And actually,
Lgr5 is important as those cells then grow, but they're not
important for the original seeding.
And then when you're at the secondary site, you then put on many others.
A very nice paper by Karuna Gunes is that once you've got there, you then produce
neoendocrine, squamous, and a whole range of markers, which is why
late stage metastasis is so difficult to treat.
So again, we can take our organoids, where we can look at the different cell
types, and we got transplant them back into colon.
And as you can see, the Wnt high and the regenerative.
And then you can also put them in the liver or let them spread from the colon.
And as you can see, we get very clear
heterogeneity within our maps. And really the biggest thing is the larger the
mets are, the more complicated and heterogeneous they come.
And so there's a real size dependency.
If you use RAS inhibitors early before they get large,
or MEK inhibition, you can really suppress all of the mets in
AKPT, so a really profound effect.
However, if you go late, you don't.So as we say, as they get more
and more complex, they get harder and harder to treat.
So then we've now looked at a whole panel of immunometabolites and
metabolites within the tumor versus normal.
And this is just really us doing DESI, going through the whole lot.
And what's very interesting is that we see many metabolites that are upregulated
between normal liver and tumor, but particularly,
adenosine is very highly upregulated within our larger tumors.
So therefore, we're seeing very clear metabolic changes.
Adenosine, again, is an immunometabolite that is happening as the tumors
get larger. We see glutamine downregulated, but we also see that
this is very highly heterogeneous, so it's only really in the larger tumors that
you start getting really good signatures of what's changed.
Again,
if we now go into the late stage and start treating these with
RAS inhibitors. So just very interesting, if we're looking at different
marks, so here's a vehicle treated, so AKPT.
You have a patch of phospho S6. This is the MAP kinase phosphorylation.
You have patches of phospho ERK. Not all of your tumor cells are phospho ERK.
Then you use the Mirati G12D compound, you completely wipe out
all the phospho ERK signaling. But as you can see, the tumor remains, but
they become quite different.
And so this is where we're seeing very quick and direct
impacts on the microenvironment.
So if we go in and just do a three-day treatment with the
G12D, what we do is see a real fall in the
circulating neutrophils, lymphocytes, and monocytes.
And just to remember, this is one of the mutant specific, so this
inhibitor is not affecting the
immune cells while the pan RASs could have effects.
And then this was a poster we put up with Brooker, which is one of the first whole
transcriptome cosmixes on mouse tissue.
But one of the biggest and most profound things is here, if we look at the CAFs
and the macrophages, normally we get these beautiful macrophage
rings around the MET. And we see this both in human and
mouse models. Ed Bard recently published a very
nice paper about the role for SPP1 macrophage surrounding.
When we use our RAS inhibitors, we no longer have this wall of
macrophages, and they sort of then move in and permit throughout
the entire MET. And we see a very similar thing with the fibroblasts as well.
So these are green CAF markers, and then basically you're getting the spreading.
So we are seeing very quick and direct effects.
So we're now going through and looking at other things that we think are going on.
So we're just repeating all our immunometabolism and metabolism panels
with and without the RAS inhibitor, and we'll be overlying that directly with
our spatial transcriptomics to sort of integrate that data together.
But just as a very interesting, this is us taking organoids, AKPT
organoids, and giving them either the KRAS G12D, and we've got on, off,
and pan, and here are the G12Cs, on, off, and pan.
And so there's been a lot of work saying what does RAS
inhibitor might do in terms of the tumor immune
microenvironment, and there are many different mechanisms.
But very interestingly, the major pathways
we're seeing across all our different organoids is GCSF and
GM-CSF.
And most of the other chemokines were actually upregulated, which was a big
surprise to us. So we think that there is a direct interaction
with tumor specific that is then driving some of these
massive changes that we're now beginning to see.
So then in summary, as I say, hopefully I've persuaded you that we're
beginning to now overlay our metabolic changes driven in vivo,
and then our next big thing is really to look very carefully of how they overlap
with their epithelial cell state.
We see a dynamic and rapid response to RAS inhibition.
That doesn't mean that it is curing tumors.
You're getting a very quick adapted
response. Mutant specific RAS inhibitors are having rapid and
potent impacts on the TME. Obviously, there's a great field really looking at
this over many years. And RAS dependent metabolic targets
can have profound impact on tumorgenesis, and we think there's benefit.
And I think we're very excited at the moment about really by able
studying these dynamic responses of tumors under different
therapeutics, we can really get great insights into both the tumor but also the
microenvironment.
And just to acknowledge all the people that did the work.
As I say, this was the sort of aftermath of a grand challenge where we were
really trying to take that on into some more of the clinically relevant models.
And so there was a great team. Very want to highlight Andy, Josephine Birch, and
Rory Stevens. We had great funding and partners across the world.
And thank you.
All right. We have some time for questions.
Mm-hmm.
Hi. It was a great presentation. I loved it.
I have a question regarding the part of colorectal cancer.
Yeah.
So
in my case, we have access to patient samples.
Yeah.
And before having the consent, you will be able to see
the genetic screening.
Yeah.
So it's a good idea to generate organoids out of it,
healthy and-
Yeah
... colon cancer and comparing these metabolic pathway.
Yeah.
So I would assume that you wanted to do it for
your further experiments as well.
One thing that crosses my mind, I mostly focuses on
cysteine and glutamate and-
Yeah
... that I was not seeing in your presentation.
I was thinking that do you have something in mind?
Plus, since the standard treatment for colorectal
cancerspecifically rectal cancer, is irradiation.
Yeah.
What do you think, instead of depleting the
anti-transporter,
like irradiating the cell to see the upgrades of the
glutathione or decrease of it?
Absolutely. So I think rectal radiotherapy is different, and we're just
doing quite a bit of work now on sort of serial of that.
And certainly, I think under radiotherapy, we see activation of
both 7A5, but also xCT, which is the
other transporter of the glutamate out.
So I think depending on your chemo, you're going to very much
rewire
these mechanisms. And I think it's then really just understanding in which
situations. And radiotherapy plus immunotherapy in
rectal is beginning to look quite good in certain situations too.
So I think there is a real window of opportunity in
microsatellite stable to really target metabolism better to then get better
responses in those. Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay, great work, Owen.
Yeah.
My question is about the last part.
So I was curious if the heterogeneity that you
see in the larger-- So when the tumors become-
Yeah
... bigger is actually due to hypoxia, and whether the effect of the
mutant
KRAS inhibitor is actually a normalization of the blood vessels
and then oxygenation, et cetera.
So
we've done a little bit of hypoxia work.
Certainly, the larger mets do become more hypoxic,
definitely.
Mm-hmm.
What we have is quite interesting because what's nice about the models
is that you can follow them as they develop.
So you can look at a week, two weeks, four weeks.
We have a really interesting change in the vasculature over
time. So they get more complicated, they get a bit more leaky and stuff like that.
So we're certainly seeing those things.
And we haven't analyzed the RAS well enough to see if it is down to the vascular
change-
Okay
... which would be very cool. Yeah.
Okay, thanks.
Yeah.
Hi. Very interesting talk.
Have you measured or can you speculate on plasma concentrations
of glutamine following your SLC deletion?
So we haven't really looked. So,
in circumstances we have done sort of serum and plasma
metabolomics. I think one of the
questions is,
as the transporter, how much are we transporting between cells into the
microenvironment, and how much is then getting in the blood?
I would imagine that you might
see changes, but at the moment, I'd have to
get the experiment done to really predict which way round it's going to be.
Yeah.
You might imagine that under stress you should see more glutamine export, higher
levels of 7A5, and therefore you might see glutamine going up in
the blood.
Right. As a potential marker for the event.
Yeah. No, that's very good.
Yeah.
We'll go back and have a look. That's a very good suggestion. Yeah.
Hi. My question actually is a little bit similar from the previous one-
Yeah
... about the timing. So actually, have you ever seen any difference
in the either Decimus or MaDi at very beginning
of the KRAS tumor development, for example, two to five
to even 10 cell clusters-
Yeah
... compared to very end stage?
So I think
one of our big changes, as we say, is the size.
And I think one of the
important things in terms of growth is as you co-opt the
microenvironment to help support you, we think that as the
early cells go in, they might
actually be cleared in part by the COPT cells, and then therefore there is a
rewiring into monocyte driven macrophages, which we think are really important
to then help them start creating that stroma.
So size is, we think, is really important.
We haven't
done so much at the very early time points to see how the metabolic
phenotypes within the tumor cells and the stroma change as that develop.
But I think it's something we're really keen to do. Yeah.
Okay. Just one follow-up then. Do you think the organoids
model can replicate that? Because I think the system is not as complicated as
the in vivo one, right?
Yeah. So what we're able to do is we can also
inject cells into the colon, and then they can
then spread. So you can do both things in this model.
And we have a whole range of organoids now
from different mouse tumors that are very good at spreading early
versus not. So we're able to sort of also mimic that
in dodgers. Because you're completely right.
If by putting loads of cells in the-- And again, I think it also talks about the
stage. If you're interested in liver met growth, injecting liver
met organoids into the liver and watching them grow is probably okay.
But if you're interested in that initial colonization stage, you
sort of overdo it with some of the really large organoid cell number.
And so what we're doing as well is doing a really careful comparison
of where you've got an autochthonous metastasis versus where you've
got injectables organoids in, just to say are you
actually permitting more cells to survive?
So some of our stuck tumors that don't grow are those ones that would never get
there. So there's a lot to do. Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah.
All right. Very quick question.
Very quick answer.
Yeah. Sorry.
Okay.
Wondering if you have introduced any co-culture or fibroblasts
into the epithelial organoid work and what your thoughts are.
Yeah. So we're doing more and more in terms of the
fibroblasts. And I think they're very important for these
regenerative
approaches. They make the organoids less proliferative and more
sort of regenerative. Yeah. Thanks.
Thank you.
Good.
Great. Thank you very much.
Okay.
Great first talk. Tough act to follow, but I'll do my best.
My name is Greg Delgoff. I'm a professor of immunology
at the University of Pittsburgh, and associate director of basic
research at the UPMC Hillman Cancer Center.
Today I'm going to be talking to you about the metabolic
consequences of T cell exhaustion and how that matters in
cancer and cancer immunotherapy.
These are my disclosures, none of which are relevant for today's talk.
So the underlying
basis of immune metabolism is that immune
responses require a massive amount of energy.
So your naive T-- And part of the reason is because the immune system sits
between two poles of extreme quiescence and extreme activation.
So naive T cells potentially wait for a lifetime in extreme
quiescence. They divide once a year.
So they don't really do a whole lot.
However, when they get activated,
very, very rapidly, they grow for 24 hours and then divide every
three hours for a solid week. So they really exist
in these two amazing states. Now, when they are activated, they're
differentiating and acquiring new effector functions.
And so they don't just need to proliferate, although they're doing a lot, they're
using a lot of energy to proliferate, but they also need to make morphologic
changes to move around the body and to intrinsically alter the
epigenome.
Effector T cells are extremely metabolically active while they are doing these
jobs. But when that antigen gets cleared
and they enter into their memory phase,
they rewire their metabolism. And they really do this at the level of the
mitochondria. They rewire their mitochondria so that they have volume,
quality, and what we call respiratory capacity that you can measure
using respirometry. This promotes longevity and increased readiness
to respond to the antigen again,
and that's been seen by several different groups.
Meanwhile, exhausted T cells, which are essentially the product of a failed immune
response in so many words, because the antigen doesn't go away,
they have repressed mitochondrial and carbohydrate metabolism that both underlies
how they become exhausted in the first place and why they fail to function when
they get there. So we've been asking for the last dozen years or so,
how do various metabolic environments shape T cell function and fates?
And we're all talking today because we're thinking about the tumor
microenvironments. This is a melanoma patient metastasis.
It's a cutaneous metastasis, and this patient has been pulsed with a hypoxia tracer
called piminidazole. And so you can actually visualize both the hypoxic core
of the tumor, but also these areas of high
metabolic activity, and you can find
T cells that are engaging in these metabolic areas.
And so this has been the study of many groups for quite some time, trying to
understand how the tumor microenvironment
metabolically alters its
local milieu,
and not only that, but what are the consequences for infiltrating immunity.
And we can use measurements of tumor microenvironment metabolism to predict
immunotherapy outcomes in many different types of cancer and in many different
types of therapy. And we and others have shown that the various metabolic
conditions in isolation can skew immunity toward different
fates of T cells. These data are old now, but
I still like to talk about them, is that if you look at T cells that infiltrate
tumors, they do so at an extreme metabolic disadvantage.
The T cells that we find infiltrating tumors have repressed
abilities to take up carbohydrates like glucose, but they really show this
dramatic mitochondrial atrophy.
As you can see, these are kind of textbook mitochondria, but the T cells that we
get from tumors have very, very small malformed mitochondria.
And this happens across many different tumor indications and it actually correlates
with responses to PD-1 blockade. At the steady state, though, the
most severe mitochondrial dysfunction is seen in the
most terminally differentiated exhausted T cells.
Okay, so the terminally exhausted T cells, not the TPs, for instance.
So what is exhaustion? It gets used a lot.
This term gets used a lot, but it actually has a fairly defined definition.
It happens when antigens don't go away.
So it's first described in chronic viral infections.
But we now know that we can characterize exhausted T cells, not just by these
markers that are on their cell surface, but really it's a functional phenotype.
It's the absence of the ability of T cells to do lots of different things.
We count on our T cells to be kind of like Swiss Army knives.
They make lots of different cytokines, and they kill, and they can
self-renew. But exhausted T cells really just eke out a little bit of gamma
interferon. They don't self-renew.
They don't really kill targets very well.
And they actually can acquire suppressive properties via generating adenosine.
Importantly, this is not a functional state of T cells.
They are a lineage that is commensurate with an epigenetic signature.
And they are not the target of immunotherapy.
In fact, where anti-PD-1 acts is on these progenitor-like exhausted T
cells that actually induce their differentiation into
cytolytic effectors and ultimately terminally exhausted T
cells. And this is a progressive phenotype. It doesn't just click on.
It happens over time and with tumor burden.
So we asked, how does metabolic stress alter the differentiation to exhaustion?
And we reported this a few years ago.
We actually broke things down using an in vitro model system where
we can exhaust otherwise healthy T cells by simply
stimulating them continuously using off-the-shelf stimulatory magnetic beads,
but doing that under hypoxic stress, just throwing the T cells into a
hypoxia chamber. And what we're able to do is pretty faithfully
recapitulate the terminally exhausted phenotype in fairly rapid succession.
You can see that here by markers. But remember what I told you a couple slides ago,
markers are only one part of the equation.
But you can look at all of these different markers and their transcription factors,
but really it is their polyfunctionality, the ability to secrete multiple
cytokines per cell, that is severely attenuated when the T cells
experience both persistent TCR stimulation and hypoxia
concurrently.You can sequence the cells, and we've done so through single
cell and RNA sequencing, as well as epigenetic analysis.
And you can see that it's not just a combination of the continuous stimulation and
hypoxia programs, but a unique,
distinct transcriptional signature that defines these cells.
And if you compare that transcriptional signature to TILs, you can see that we
have very nice correlation with terminally exhausted T cells that we isolate
ex vivo. Now, why am I telling you all this story?
I thought I was talking about mitochondria.
Well, as it turns out, we can use models like this to understand
how mitochondria change as a consequence of continuous stimulation.
And so here's
just an initial summary that the continuous TCR stimulation promotes a
mitochondrial phenotype that makes them sensitive to hypoxia, and it drives
an exhausted-like phenotype. And we've shown in other
publications that hypoxia
produces ROS, it mimics chronic signaling, but it also alters
the methylation state of the epigenome.
Now, I told you, you came in here to talk about mitochondria.
So this is now unpublished work, and so how does this happen?
How do immunologic signals talk to the mitochondria and change them?
Our data, we're now suggesting that unlike what we saw in 2016,
these T cells were not losing their mitochondria.
Their mitochondria were changing.
And what do chronic and tonic TCR
signals do to the mitochondria? And what does that mean for the
cell? So in other words, how do immunologic signals crosstalk with both the
nucleus and the mitochondrion?
Now, unfortunately, because of fifth-grade science class, we have
a very skewed view of what mitochondria do.
I think you all, no matter if you're metabolism people or not, we all know what
you're supposed to say about mitochondria.
But it turns out we have a very skewed view.
Yes, we do indeed have the ability to take
pyruvates and make ATP in all of the ways that you remember and memorized when
you were in undergraduate biochemistry.
However, mitochondria are so much more than just the powerhouses.
They regulate cell death, they buffer calcium and other second messengers,
and they generate ROS that is very critical for biochemistry to be
performed. But also mitochondria produce dozens of
biomolecules that serve many purposes in the cell, and that makes them far more
like processors than powerhouses, okay?
They're a signaling router in so many ways.
So we really wanted to take this on.
And so one way we started to look at this is we went right back to the same old
things we were doing, and we noticed something that if we sorted out the
individual subsets of cells, the Tpex-like population, but also
the more terminally exhausted T cells, and we went back to our electron
microscopy, we were always focused on the mitochondria.
But one thing that we found was that lymph node T cells have these
small lipid droplets, but the Tpex population, they start to
accumulate lipids. But look at the exhausted T cells.
They have these giant lipid droplets everywhere throughout the
cytosol of the cell. And you can even measure this by a dye called
BODIPY that stains neutral lipids, and you can see exhausted T cells are just
loaded with lipid. And you can, of course,
look at this even by flow cytometry, just by staining them with BODIPY.
We also saw an accumulation of acetylated proteins across the
entire proteome as T cells progressed to this terminally exhausted
state. So this was interesting. These cells were not like not taking up
carbon. They were actually full of carbon. So what was happening there?
We could absolutely reproduce this in our in vitro system.
So chronic stimulation could drive a little bit on its own, but if you added
hypoxic stress, the T cells accumulated lipids and they
accumulated the acetylated lysine across their proteome.
So what was actually happening here, and how was this happening?
So we wanted to look at the mitochondria of these cells, and we've done this both
by RNA sequencing and by proteomics.
And here was our hypothesis, that good effector memory like T cells,
their mitochondria were places where carbon went to be burned to
generate energy. However, exhausted T cells, their
mitochondria may be more
exporters. And this is absolutely borne out by looking at the family
of genes that actually exchange carbon in and out of the mitochondria.
This is the SLC25 family. And for the rest of the talk, I'm going to focus
on the canonical member of this family called SLC25A1, which
gets activated in effector memory T cells but stays highly
upregulated as T cells become exhausted in tumors.
So what is this 25A1, and why are we interested in it?
Well, it encodes a citrate carrier.
The citrate carrier. The mitochondrial citrate carrier, which removes
citrate from the TCA cycle and it enters into the
cytosol of cells. In the cytosol of cells, citrate can
be converted back into acetyl-CoA, where it either forms lipids through
de novo lipogenesis or acetylates proteins, the two
things that we saw occurring in T cells as they progress to
exhaustion.
And we could show that while activation can acutely
turn on the mitochondrial citrate carrier, chronic stimulation and especially
hypoxic stress drove the persistent upregulation of this
citrate carrier, providing an exit for carbon
outside of the mitochondria and outside of the TCA cycle.
So,
could we actually see the citrate leaving
the mitochondria and going to the cytosol?
Well, we'd have to fractionate cells to do this.
And if you've ever looked at a T cell under the microscope, it's about all nucleus
and a tiny little bit of cytosol. So you can't really fractionate them.
But Bing Zhang in the lab
was able to repurpose a
citrate sensor that is based on circularly permutated
GFP, and we were able to transduce T cells and then park the sensor either in
the cytosol or in the mitochondria of T cells.
And you can see, consistent with our hypotheses, chronic stimulation under
hypoxia does promote the accumulation of both mitochondrial
citrate and cytosolic citrate, telling us that
this metabolic pathway was occurring in the context of chronic
stimulation.We also saw acetylation across the
entire proteome. You can see this based on the laddering on
this western blot, which we have tabulated here.
And so we wanted to identify some of those hyperacetylated proteins.
So we did this in our in vitro system.
These data are still under analysis, but you can see many, many mitochondrial genes
and metabolic proteins are hyperacetylated, but
also really critical transcription factors in T cell biology, including
the stemness factor TCF7,
RUNX3, and BCF3. So both the metabolic
and immunologic machinery is being hyperacetylated as a consequence
of this altered metabolic pathway.
So how does the citrate carrier contribute to T cell exhaustion?
And so the way that we did this is by simply targeting SLC25A1, the gene
that encodes the citrate carrier, and asking what happens.
So we just used CRISPR
to knock out this gene in T cells. Now, we then put them through the wringer
and started doing metabolic profiling.
And what I hope you can appreciate here, remember I showed you that respiratory
capacity, that value of
mitochondria that promotes longevity and increased
responses to
re-stimulation. When we knock out the citrate carrier and prevent the citrate
from leaving the mitochondria, now we have a very
superior oxidative phenotype with high respiratory capacity in these
cells.
But these cells also do more glycolysis as measured by the SEAR.
So they're actually able to do better glucose metabolism as well, which at first
seemed kind of vexing, but then we, again, went back to our undergraduate
biochemistry that we all memorized, and it turns out citrate is a allosteric
inhibitor of phosphofructokinase.
So when you don't just keep the carbon in the mitochondria, you also
prevent its negative feedback for the rest of things.
So all in all, these cells were much better, were
metabolically superior to typical
T cells.
So what did that mean when we put them in vitro?
So we took antigen-specific T cells on congenitally mismatched
backgrounds. We either
non-targeted or targeted SLC25A1, mixed them 50/50, and
put them into tumor-bearing mice.
And I hope you can appreciate here that now those T cells no longer accumulate
lipid when we've blocked this kind of off-ramp for
citrate in the mitochondria.
But more importantly, these cells, this is in the same tumor microenvironment.
Okay? So this is a 50/50 mix. And you can see while the lymph node phenotypes are
not really there because they're not really seeing much chronic antigen in the
tumor, these T cells are far less likely to progress to terminal exhaustion,
both by PD-1, TIM-3, but also by the expression of the terminal exhaustion marker
CD39. But again, we can't just look at their cell surface phenotype, take
anything away from this talk, that's it.
You can see that they're functionally far more polyfunctional.
They secrete more cytokines per cell, TNF, gamma interferon.
But one of the biggest signatures we see is their ability to synthesize
IL-2, both in the lymph node and in the tumor microenvironments.
And we know this is really critical.
It's the first thing to go in exhaustion is IL-2 production, but we still see that
happening here. The T cells are also
therapeutically superior. This is without any lymphodepletion or anything else like
that, just a bulk transfer of 10 million T cells.
And you can see that if we target the citrate carrier, those T cells
are able to
eliminate tumors to a greater degree.
And this also synergizes very well with PD-1
blockade. Okay. So to conclude this part of the talk,
actually the talk in general, TCR stimulation talks directly
to the mitochondrial machinery. So especially chronic stimulation remodels the
mitochondria away from being importers to becoming exporters.
One of these transporters, and we're targeting all members of the SLC25 family to
explore this, but one is the citrate carrier encoded by
25A1, and it's upregulated by both TCR stimulation and
metabolic stress. And that cytosolic citrate is converted to
acetyl-CoA, where it can form lipid droplets as well as hyperacetylate
proteins. The acetylation affects key proteins involved in T cell
metabolism and identity, and we can either block or delete the citrate carrier
and alter the course of T cell differentiation.
AI is good for some things. It's not really
great for drawing pictures, but it's a better artist than I am.
But I think we have this idea. I've always used this idea that
exhausted T cells are tired. Okay? So I kind of have things like this.
They're
tired. They are starving. They can't get access to carbon.
But one of the things that we're learning simply by looking at them is that there
are two ways to become exhausted. You can be exhausted because you're starving,
but you can also be exhausted because you don't want to get off the couch.
So it's probably more that exhausted T cells have a phenotype of obesity
as opposed to a phenotype of
not having a lot of carbon. I'd like to thank my microenvironment.
This is a team effort, but this was really driven first initially by my first
graduate student, Nicole Scharping, and it's been followed up beautifully by
Kelly Sparr, an incredible graduate student in the lab.
I'd also like to thank key collaborators that helped us do the proteomics, our
funding sources, and you all for your attention. Happy to take any questions.
Hey, Greg. Fantastic talk. Jelani Zarif right here.
Hey, Jelani.
Fantastic talk. I was wondering about the knockouts.
I'm wondering if you had thought about some poly IC-inducible model
to see if you could let tumors grow, then give poly IC to see if
that mutation will attenuate tumorigenesis in vivo.
Yeah. So everything we're doing right now is adoptive transfer and CRISPR and
things like that.
Okay.
But we've now made the floxed allele, and we're deleting it both in all CD8
T cells as well as only in terminally differentiated T cells.
Yeah.
And so we're going to be playing around with this a lot to think about.
And the problem is, as was beautifully highlighted by John Wherry yesterday,
all of our mouse tumor models grow way too quickly to do these really fun
experiments where you can treat them for a while and then see what happens.
So ultimately, we're now trying to find tumor models that grow
over a long period of time and that we can start to think about it.
But it's a huge unmet need in the field, but we're playing around with being able
to do some of these modulations you're talking about.
Thank you.
Hi, Dave Guirus, UT San Antonio. I'm a little more
interested in the fatty acid oxidation, which you really didn't
comment about, but you were hinting at, right?
With the accumulation of
fatty
lipids in the mitochondria, and I'm wondering if you've
added BSA conjugated fatty acids in different...
And what you're seeing.
Yeah, it's a great question. I didn't have time to talk about it today, but
we've really been focusing on what these lipids do.
So one thing is that the entire fatty acid oxidation machinery is repressed in
exhausted T cells, so you can, as a gene signature.
So, and this is due to a number of things, but including the repression
of PGC1 alpha, and many PPAR
signatures. So we've actually really thought about what happens if we take T cells
and kind of force them to do fatty acid oxidation because they don't do a
lot of it, right? And so we've just used off-the-shelf things like
rosiglitazone and bezafibrates to stimulate that.
And what it causes them to do is to
actually start breaking down those lipids, and then they start proliferating again.
And so one of the things that I didn't talk about today is just the use of
rosiglitazone to either expand T cells from tumors
or to cause them to induce fatty acid oxidation in vivo.
And so we're playing around with what those things are going to do.
But what the consequences are of having these big
lipid droplets in the cell, there are many possible things.
We know that lipid droplets can suppress inflammatory signaling, like STING
activation, other things like this.
So these are all things that we're exploring in the future. But great question.
Hi, Dr. Delgo. That was a beautiful talk.
My name is Shireen from Utah.
I was wondering whether glutamine also acts as a
source for the citrate accumulation through reductive carboxylation.
And do you think there is a preferential source of carbon for this
citrate?
So we think it's mostly glucose derived, based on our
analyses. We have traced carbon and
blocked
glutaminolysis, and this still occurs.
So we see the vast majority of citrate accumulation occurring from
glucose sources, not so much from glutamine.
Thank you.
But great question.
Tim Ozier, responsible to be in. Really interested in
why is citrate not going into the TCA cycle?
Is it just there's too much flux in and not enough enzymatic
degradation? What's happening with downstream TCA metabolites,
AKG, succinate?
Yeah. Both great questions. So what we see is a massive accumulation.
If we do mass spec, and we can't do mass spec on mitochondrial versus
cytosolic. But if we do carbon tracing, we see,
just in whole, we see a massive accumulation of citrates and
a massive downregulation of everything downstream, alpha-ketoglutarate,
succinate, and so on. So one of the important pieces of this is that the most--
It's not just the expression of the citrate carrier, and that's where we think the
hypoxia is involved here, too.
One of the most ROS sensitive enzymes in your proteome is aconitase.
It's got an iron sulfur cluster, and so that gets rapidly
inactivated by exposure to ROS. So we think it's both
the inhibition of aconitase and the expression of the citrate carrier are linked,
and that's what promotes this shunting of citrate out of the mitochondria.
And then can you rescue with AKG?
We've done a little bit of DEMOG work.
The problem is it also
stabilizes HIF1 alpha and stuff like that.
Yeah.
So it's a little bit tough to do, but it's a good question.
We have done it, but I'm not sure what the results are yet.
Thank you.
Hey, Dr. Delgo. This is Iman from Mayo Clinic. Great talk as usual.
Were you able to confirm the overexpression of SLC25 in
human samples, like in human TILs?
Or-
Yes. So this is something we've been doing quite a lot of lately.
So both by staining human TILs as well as by
mining publicly available single cell data, we can show that
25A1 is upregulated commensurate with T cell exhaustion in a number of
different tumor types. There's also people who
have
mutations. It's an inborn error of metabolism in SLC25A1, and we can use
their T cells to explore some of these things.
We have a cohort of patients with mutations.
Great. So in term of your in vivo work, we don't see a
total regression. So what's your plan like as
combination to, well, with the SLC25?
So 25A1 is actually druggable.
Before GLP-1s, if you didn't want to eat, you ate
Garcinia. Garcinia's like that cactus.
And hydroxycitrate is an allosteric inhibitor of the citrate carrier.
So we're exploring ways to drug 25A1 in ways that are either
in T cells or that potentially treating the whole animal.
But it is a druggable
target.
Okay. Thank you so much.
We're running out of time, so just one quick question each, and then we'll go on.
Okay. Very interesting findings.
I have a question with regard to the phenotype that you see on the mitochondria and
the swollen mitochondria and the lipid droplets.
I was wondering, this is quite reminiscent to what you see when you have
impairment of autophagy. So do you have any indication that
autophagy or inhibition of autophagy could be involved also in your
phenotype?
Yes. So
both autophagy and mitophagy are altered as a consequence of
chronic TCR stimulation. Ping-Chi Ho in Lausanne has
beautiful work about disrupted mitophagy as a consequence of
T cell exhaustion.
So in your screen, you don't see any of those genes related or mTORC1, for
example, signaling affected?
The regulation of TOR complex 1 in exhaustion is
complex.
Yeah.
Many features of its signaling are chronically upregulated.
Other things are repressed.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
That was beautiful and complex biology.
Can you separate the acetylation phenotype versus the lipid droplet size?
Because I'm coming from the adipose world and the lipid droplet size can
restrict transcription factor traffic.
So the lipid droplet proteome might actually be a reservoir of
exhaustion factors that you could target just by hitting lipolytic signals.
Ah, boyThis is just like what we've been trying to do for three years.
Yeah.
How do you take this apart?
Because you can inhibit some pieces, but once you get to acetyl-CoA,
if we inhibit ACLY-
Exactly
... we completely rescue the phenotype.
We
can confirm the phenotype. But
after that, it's hard to dissociate the acetylation-
Yeah
... which is so broad, and we don't even think it's acetyltransferase.
We just think it's just so much acetyl-CoA that it's just
binding. But the lipid stuff we're going after with ACC inhibitors, we're
going after with TOFA. I'll let you know in a year.
All right. Thanks very much for your questions.
Really, really great discussions.
It's great to see people so excited about this field.
It's my pleasure now to invite Dr. Madar up, who's coming to
us from MD Anderson, who's going to tell us about metabolism in
NK cells as a feature of cellular therapies.
Good morning, everyone. Thank you so much for the invitation,
and it's my pleasure to be here today to talk to you about NK cell
metabolism and how we can reprogram it to enhance our adoptive cell therapy.
These are my disclosures. None of them are relevant for today's talk.
So we know that you've heard the tumor microenvironment is very
complex. Of course, there's interplay between various immune cells,
tumor cells, stromal cells, et cetera.
And there's a lot of metabolic competition
leading to scarce resources, so nutrient deprivation,
hypoxia, accumulation of lactate, which leads to acidosis,
accumulation of toxic metabolites, and all of these factors lead to
immunosuppression and suppression of the effector function of our
NK cells in the tumor microenvironment.
So in fact, we have some evidence from our clinical trials if we
compare the infusion product
before it goes into the patients and post-infusion
samples that we derive from the patients.
We see significant downregulation of key metabolic
processes, including oxidative phosphorylation, fatty acid metabolism,
glycolysis. And significant downregulation of key
signaling pathways such as mTOR, MEK, IL-2, STAT5, et cetera.
So these NK cells, once they enter the tumor microenvironment,
they are losing metabolic fitness and
becoming dysfunctional
following that. So there is a lot of metabolic competition between
tumor cells and immune effector cells because these cells rely on the same
resources. They really need amino acids, including glutamine,
glucose, fatty acids for them to grow and do their function.
And tumor cells have evolved to be very efficient at uptaking these
nutrients and metabolizing them.
So what's really happening is that the tumor cells are thriving, growing,
and starving the immune effector cells in the tumor microenvironment.
And what we're trying to do with our various immuno-metabolic strategies in the
lab is to skew this balance in favor of the immune effector
cells in order for them to work better in the tumor microenvironment
and outcompete the tumor cells. And there are multiple
opportunities to modulate immune effector cell metabolism before adoptive cell
therapy. You can do it at various stages.
You can even start from the choice of the starting material.
So the NK cell source really matters, and I'll show you a little bit of an example.
The vector design, the choice of the costimulatory molecule, the choice of the
cytokine payload, all of this plays into affects the
metabolism of the cells. And then the period of CAR manufacturing
and culturing, the ex vivo culturing period
provides a lot of opportunities for reprogramming the
metabolism of immune effector cells through the choice of cytokines
that you use to expand your cells, the media composition, and the nutrient
composition of the media, the use of various pharmacologic
modulators, inhibitors, and activators during the culturing system.
And then
playing with genetic modifications.
You've heard about CRISPR gene knockouts, and we're playing a lot
with CRISPR and gene overexpression in order to enhance
or downregulate certain
genes that are important for metabolic fitness of the cells.
And then finally, at the infusion stage, you're able also to combine
your immune effector cells with varied pharmacologic combinations in order
to optimize their metabolic function.
So I'll start with a little bit of a snippet on the starting material.
This is in collaboration with Dr. Ken Cheng group at MD Anderson.
Bakul Mohanty and Mervie Dede did this single-cell RNA sequencing
analysis where they compared cord blood NK cells versus peripheral
blood NK cells, and there are certain clusters you can see in
the single-cell RNA seq that are very enriched in cord blood compared
to peripheral blood. And when we focus on these
clusters, clusters six, seven, and eight, we can see they're highly enriched in
various metabolic pathways compared to clusters
that are enriched in peripheral blood.
And when we look at the number of differentially expressed metabolic processes in
these cord blood enriched clusters, they're much higher compared to the peripheral
blood
enriched clusters. And at the product level, the cord blood
NK cells
show this metabolic diversity compared to peripheral blood.
This is better portrayed here in the circus plot, where cord blood in red is
showing enrichment in amino acid metabolism, carbohydrate metabolism,
lipid metabolism, et cetera. So they're much more
metabolically diverse compared to peripheral blood NK cells, and we're
studying that further in the lab and validating it at the functional
level. So moving on to some of the strategies we've
used in theCAR manufacturing and culturing stage, we
played a little bit with nutrient composition of the media.
This is work done by a very talented postdoc in the lab, Silvia Tiberti,
who's here and who's going to be presenting her poster tomorrow.
But basically, instead of growing NK cells with the regular
NK cell media, which is either RPMI clicks or
SCGM, she cultured the NK cells in this APEL media.
APEL media is usually used in iPSC differentiation
during embryoid body formation. And she chose that media just because
its composition, it's very enriched in essential lipids such
as oleic acid, linoleic acid, cholesterol, et cetera, and she was
curious to see what it would do to the NK cells.
So she cultured the NK cells, whether they are non-transduced or transduced with
the CD70 CAR NK cells with a CD70 CAR vector,
and then looked at their metabolism.
And both mitochondrial mass and potential were enriched in the
APEL-grown NK cells compared to the standard media.
And you can see here by confocal imaging,
these mitochondria are more elongated, they're aggregated,
they're polarized compared to mitochondria of NK cells grown
in standard media, where they are more rounded, more dispersed in
this perinuclear
disposition. And then when she looked functionally,
these NK cells grown in APEL media show
enhanced oxidative phosphorylation.
Both basal respiration and spare respiratory capacity are increased.
And when she performed some metabolic flexibility assays,
she saw that the NK cells, after inhibiting certain
metabolic pathways individually, the NK cells grown in regular
NK cell media are suffering, basically decreasing maximal
respiration significantly, whereas the NK cells grown in
APEL media are maintaining a high level of maximal
respiration. So without any genetic engineering, she was able to
generate cells with improved metabolic fitness.
And then does that translate to better functionality?
Silvia has a lot of data that she can show you in her poster, but this is just an
example of one of her re-challenge assays that she performed
against MOLM14, which is an AML leukemia cell
line. Basically, this is a re-challenge assay, so every
two to three days she adds tumor again.
The lower the curve, the better the killing.
You see the APEL-grown NK cells are performing much better here in
purple compared to NK cells grown in regular media.
And this, she has data in various tumor
models, including solid tumors,
pancreatic cancer, ovarian cancer, et cetera, so it's not disease specific.
And then in vivo, they perform much better and lead to survival advantage in the
mice. And then when she extracted these NK cells from the
mice and looked at their metabolic
capacity, they still retain their metabolic advantage with higher
mitochondrial mass and potential.
So it's not just when they're cultured in the media.
They're having some form of epigenetic remodeling, and she
has data through ATAC-seq looking at their
epigenetic
function, basically. So the media is reprogramming the NK
cells at the epigenetic level and metabolic level
in order to enhance their persistence and improve the cytotoxic activity.
This is her working model. So basically she's created this metabolically
primed NK cells through just changing the
media, basically enhancing their metabolic fitness, cytotoxic activity,
proliferation, et cetera. And if you're interested to know more, please visit her
poster. She's speaking tomorrow morning.
So now moving on to some other strategies we've used in the lab.
CRISPR gene editing has been a big part of our journey, combining it with CAR
modification. So one of the first metabolic checkpoints we went
after was CIS or cytokine-inducible SH2-containing
protein. This was a few years ago, so I won't spend too much time, and
it's published. But basically, it's a major metabolic checkpoint in NK cells
that acts as a negative regulator of JAK-STAT signaling downstream of
IL-2 and IL-15.
It's highly upregulated in our CAR NK cells
because all our CAR NK cells include interleukin-15, which
basically upregulates this metabolic checkpoint.
When we knock it out, we enrich for
mTOR signaling, glycolysis, interferon gamma response, IL-2,
STAT5, which is
expected since it's a negative regulator of JAK-STAT signaling.
But when we use these cells, basically for adoptive cell
therapy in mice model, they really make a big difference in
multiple models. This is here in a
very aggressive Raji lymphoma mouse
model that's non-curative, and we had really
significant improvement in survival in these mice.
So by basically
deleting a metabolic checkpoint, we're able to rewire these cells in order for
them to function better in the tumor microenvironment.
Another major negative regulator that we focus on a lot is
TGF-beta, which is what we call old but gold.
It's really not very sexy, but it's very important.
It's a major
immunosuppressant for NK cells and other immune effector
cells in the tumor microenvironment of both hematologic malignancies and solid
tumors. And in addition to it being an immunosuppressant,
it's a major metabolic regulator because TGF-beta has been shown to have
direct inhibitory effect on mTOR, decreasing glycolysis, and
direct inhibitory effect on OXPHOS due to its
effects on complex one and complex four.So,
recently we've published that TGF-beta plays a very important role
in AML,
NK cell functions. So NK cells from AML and MDS
patients are very dysfunctional.
They don't kill, basically, AML cells.
They also have very altered metabolism.
And a big part of their dysfunction, we showed that is related to
TGF-beta signaling. Again, this work is published, so I won't be
spending too much time on it. But basically, through a cell-cell contact dependent
mechanism, TGF-beta gets released from the myeloid blast,
binding to the TGF-beta receptor complex, leading to phosphorylation of
SMAD2/3. This complex then translocates to the nucleus and
upregulates a transcription factor called BATF that basically
rewires the whole-- leads to an epigenetic reprogramming of the cells,
leading to irreversible dysfunction.
To prevent that, we went after the TGF-beta receptor II,
CRISPRed it out, and combined it with our CAR transduction, and
we've created, really, NK cells that function much better in vivo
in leukemia models,
as you can see here in this example.
So with that work, preclinical work, we took this
approach to the clinic. And this is a Phase 1/2 clinical
trial that is now open and enrolling at MD Anderson, testing the safety and
efficacy of TGF-beta receptor II knockout CD70 CAR NK cells
for the treatment of relapsed refractory AML. It's led by Dr.
Nick Short in the leukemia department. It's basically a dose escalation phase.
Patients would receive flucytosine for depletion, and then on day zero
receive these off-the-shelf, completely frozen
CD70 CAR NK cells.
Yes. And then this approach also with the same cell bank,
we opened another clinical trial
for the treatment of relapsed refractory renal cell carcinoma, since
TGF-beta is also a very important metabolic suppressant and
immunosuppressant in the solid tumor microenvironment, and specifically
renal cell carcinoma. This trial is led by Dr. Pablos M.
Sawal in the GU department at MD Anderson.
It's also open and enrolling, and the same design, basically, with
dose escalation. Okay, so now moving on to some unpublished
work with gene overexpression that we're very excited about.
This strategy was inspired by how viruses, when they
infect host cells, they can hijack the metabolism of these
host cells for their own purposes in order to make more viral
particles. And each virus does it in a specific way.
A human adenovirus uses this gene called E4ORF1,
or early region four open reading frame one.
And when it's translated, this protein, basically, what it does, it
binds to PI3KDLG1 in a trimeric complex
on the inner
cell membrane. It phosphorylates AKT, activates mTOR,
and then E4ORF1 also binds to making the nucleus leading to increase in
MYC-dependent biosynthetic pathways.
This has been published in the setting of infection, of adenovirus
infection. So how after the adenovirus infects the whole cell, what does
it do to its metabolism? And then we were inspired by this and said,
"Why don't we introduce this gene in our NK cells and see what happens?"
Basically, the hypothesis was, if we introduce that gene in the NK cells, we're
able to increase their metabolic fitness, their
flexibility, enhancing their OXPHOS, glycolysis, enhancing their
competition with the tumors, and eventually leading to better cytotoxicity in the
tumor microenvironment. And indeed, these E4ORF1 engineered NK
cells show very significant enhancement in glycolysis and
increase in oxidative phosphorylation.
And what's interesting, their mitochondrial mass and potential are
both increased, but under starvation.
You can see that very evident here in the confocal imaging, where under
regular conditions, maybe there's a little bit of an increase, but under
starvation, these cells significantly enhance
their mitochondrial potential, and the mitochondrial area
is much more increased compared to the control NK
cells. At the signaling level, these E4ORF1 engineered NK
cells upregulate key enzymes related to glycolysis, both at
steady-state conditions and after stimulation with CD16.
So hexokinase 2, LDHA are both increased significantly.
With glutaminolysis also, these
engineered NK cells show enhancement in SLC1A5
expression and glutaminase expression, and then also they
show increase in CD36 and CPT1A expression, so fatty
acid metabolism is also affected.
So you can see it's not really leading to a single pathway improvement.
It's doing this multimodal increase in metabolic
pathways like viruses usually do.
And then at the transcriptomic level, when we compared E4ORF1 engineered NK
cells to control NK cells, they show enrichment in various inflammatory
pathways, interferon alpha response, interferon gamma response,
JAK-STAT signaling, IL2, STAT5, et cetera.
And interestingly, all these pathways remain
enriched even under glucose starvation, glutamine starvation, or
lipid starvation.
This translates to better killing capacity against various solid tumor cell
lines, including colorectal carcinoma, triple-negative breast cancer, pancreatic
adenocarcinoma, renal cell carcinomas, and many others.
So this is not disease specific. These E4ORF1 engineered NK cells
are able to enhance the killing efficacy of our NK cells
in multiple models, and they're able to do
so even under starved conditions.
So under glutamine starvation or glucose starvations, these cells
maintain their advantage in killing.
And then we thought about what could be common to all.
What could beUpstream of all these metabolic
pathways that could be
enriching for this metabolic fitness, we thought of
AMP kinase as a central nutrient sensor in the cell, and we saw that
E4ORF1 really increases phosphorylation of AMP kinase alpha
and total AMP kinase alpha expression in the cells.
And then we see here, this is a spheroid assay, so incucyte
live-cell imaging with spheroids labeled with GFP.
You can see the controls, the non-transduced, and the empty vector NK cells do not
function very well. When you introduce the E4ORF1 NK cells, they kill
really well.
After five days, you can see complete ablation of the tumor.
But in the presence of AMP kinase inhibition, this phenotype is completely
abrogated. So basically, AMP kinase is playing a central
role in mediating the phenotype of E4ORF1 in this setting.
Then we ask ourself, is this still relevant in the CAR setting?
Because the CAR NK cells, the CAR itself can modulate the
metabolism, the interleukin 15 that's present in our CARs also
modulate metabolism. So is E4ORF1 still relevant in
that setting? And we saw that even CAR-engineered NK
cells that express E4ORF1 have increase in
glycolysis and oxidative phosphorylation.
They have improved capacity for serial killing and serial rechallenge
assays, and they lead to better outcomes in our mouse models.
And if you're interested to know more about the mechanism, please visit
Madison Moore's
poster tomorrow morning. He's going to be talking to you more about that.
So in conclusion, there are really multiple strategies to reprogram NK cell
metabolism. I've touched on some of the approaches we're
doing in the lab, but there are many more
that we're trying, and we're very excited these strategies can be really leveraged
to enhance the persistence and the efficacy of NK cells to
overcome some of the challenges in the TME and improve the outcomes of our
adoptive cell therapy approaches.
So with that, I'd like to end and thank everyone who has been involved in this
work. The support of the Cell Therapy Institute led by Dr.
Katy Rezvani, the Stem Cell Transplant Department and all its members,
all our collaborators, the Core Blood Bank, and especially my
wonderful team. Silvia and Madison are going to be here and will be
presenting their poster tomorrow. And, yeah, the funding agencies.
Thank you so much, and I'll be very happy to take questions.
All right, we have some time for a couple of questions.
Hey. Great talk. So, regarding the
E4ORF1 overexpression, so it clearly
increases
the metabolic activity. So have you looked at the persistence and the
viability of the cells? And also,
MYC, it has broad
transcriptional activity. So have
you looked at other targets besides metabolism?
And can we translate this into T cells?
Yes. These are all great questions.
Regarding the persistence, we've looked and actually,
this is part of why we want to do this, because we want to increase the persistence
of the cells in the solid tumor microenvironment.
We have prelim data showing increased persistence in our mouse models.
But definitely, yes, we think this is part of why they perform so
much better also in the serial killing assays and in vivo.
Regarding the MYC, yes, we think it's actually
these E4ORF1 NK cells are increasing a lot
biosynthesis. Basically, a lot of the biosynthetic pathways in the cells, and
we have
very nice data. I think Madison's going to present some of his western blot
results tomorrow in the poster, so please pass by.
And then the third question was regarding if we tried it in T cells.
We're actively trying in CAR T cells. We think it's not cell specific.
It's important to test it in other immune cells as well.
Very great questions.
Wonderful. Thank you.
Thank you.
Technical questions regarding the Apel media.
Have you tried doing a similar experiment with T and CAR T?
So is this NK cell specific, or is it generalizable to-
Yeah
... adoptive cell therapy?
Yeah. Great question, too. And actually, Silvia is trying it with both T
cells and monocytes. But yeah, we're very interested to test it,
not just in NK. Great question.
And have you compared it to X-Max media?
We have not, but we're trying
other medias, but we haven't tried X-Max.
Thank you.
Yeah. Welcome.
I was wondering whether you think that this metabolic rewiring
affects only downstream signaling or also proximal
NK signaling.
We're talking about E4ORF1, which strategy,
basically?
Yes.
The E4ORF1. Yes, we're looking into all that.
We're actually exploring the
phenotype, of course, of these cells, upregulation of multiple NK cell
receptors and
NK cells, of course, can kill through multiple mechanisms.
So we're trying to, for example, test these cells in combination
with CD16 activation or for
ADCC or
different other NK cell receptor activation and see how they
crosstalk with downstream metabolic pathways
upregulated by E4ORF1.
Thank you.
Great question.
That was great talk. So I have a question about starvation.
The previous speaker, you also showed the change in
mitochondrial fitness is when there is starvation.
Mm-hmm. Yes.
So does it have anything to do with mitophagy in your case?
Yes.
Absolutely. So AMP kinase also is a major regulator of
autophagy, so we're testing that.
And I think, yes, I think part of it is related to autophagy.
And one more question. Did you see what kind of nutrient or
essential component in the medias that you use, the Apel
media-
The Apel media
... in your-
Yeah. So this Apel media actually contains...
I didn't have time to go through the details, but it contains
You know, ascorbic acid, it contains essential lipids, as I
said, oleic acid, linoleic acid, and cholesterol.
It has also insulin. So we're testing some of
the components in the media individually and in combination to see
which component of the media could be responsible.
But we think it's really a combination of multiple components, not a
single element. Great question.
I was wondering, did you see a difference in the oxylipin productions
of these NK cells?
In?
Oxylipins.
We haven't looked.
Thank you.
Great talk. Sharon from the NCI.
I had a question about your starvation assays, where you show increased metabolic
fitness under glucose-deprived glutamine and fatty acid
conditions. Can you speculate or comment on what
fuel, what source of fuel the mitochondria are using to sustain the
NK cells?
Yeah, we're actively actually trying to understand.
I don't think it's a single fuel. As I said, I think it's
multiple. So
these viral-- I think that's why this approach is important,
because viruses have evolved through the years to
rewire the metabolism of host cells in various ways, and I don't think
it's relying on a single fuel. I think it's a combination of multiple
metabolic optimizations within the cells.
But we're looking specifically, we're doing carbon tracing, et cetera, to
understand the specifics. Yes, great question.
Okay.
Great. We have 10 minutes left
for a panel discussion. So if you guys don't want to keep
walking all the way down that
hallway, we can talk a little bit. Owen, would you like to come up?
You guys can have a seat. Any questions that maybe you didn't get a chance to
answer or that you're thinking about broadly, and we'll take it away from
there. Anybody got any thoughts?
Great talk, Dr. Delgoff. It's for you.
So after deletion of a citrate carrier,
did you see how does it affect PD-L1 levels on the tumor
cells? Like, does it have any indirect accumulation of PD-L1 because PD-1
is reducing or the other exhaustion curves are reducing?
So we don't see... If anything, we see elevated levels of PD-L1 in the
tumor because the cells are making more gamma interferon.
Mm-hmm.
And that's causing a kind of heating up, if you will, of the tumor
microenvironments.
But yeah, we think it's pretty direct just based on the effector
function of the T cells.
Okay. My other question is, have you seen how does it affect indirectly
myeloid cell population, or does it have any interaction with other
myeloid cells?
We haven't looked, although several people have studied the citrate carrier in
myeloid cells. I'm not familiar with the data.
Thank you.
Just curious about the lipid accumulation in the
cells. Did you look at the functionality of the peroxisome?
In general, peroxisomes are very poorly functional in terminally
differentiated T cells. We've explored this a little bit.
But essentially, and this is very commensurate with
the repression of the PPAR
machinery.
Hi. Also, this is a question for Dr. Delgoff.
And it's very interesting to see this lipid association.
And I keep thinking about there may be an association between
this lipid accumulation in T cells, as well as some relevance to the
lipid-associated macrophages or other.
So I was wondering if these T cells were
also changing the phenotype by
incorporating lipid from outside, not just
changing the metabolic flux. And also, do you see any
association with those lipid-associated macrophages
in a tumor microenvironment?
Yeah, this is a great question. So in our in vitro system, we were able to
tackle this by simply using charcoal-stripped media.
And so we just removed all the lipids, and they still accumulate lipid to the exact
same degree. So we think all of this is through de novo lipogenesis and not
from accumulation of lipids from the outside.
We've also blocked CD36, which is kind of a fake experiment, but we did that
too. And it didn't have any effect on our system.
Thanks.
That was a great session.
With regards to the last talk and the mitochondrial mass
expansion under glucose starvation, there's an old bit of
biology of PGC1alpha acetylation.
I just wanted to find out if you were investigating exactly that.
Yes, absolutely. And they actually increase PGC1alpha and PPAR gamma,
so great question.
So does that also associate with acetylation of some of the other transcriptional
targets that might be involved in tuning mitochondrial phenotypes-
Yes
... in association with the PGC1?
So we're actually looking, yes, but you're right on point. Yes.
So follow-up. I know the anti-aging space is
tarnished.
But I like drinking wine, and the resveratrol was compelling.
Is there any evidence that any of those WEEKS or
TUINs, because the PGC1alpha effect is supposedly a sirtuin effect,
any evidence that exogenous sirtuin perturbations could be a benefit to this
particular pathway?
I
suppose so. We haven't done experiments, but yeah, great
points. And we're actually testing resveratrol in combination.
I've always wanted to test this. And yes.
It has good effects on the cells.
Yes, I'll also-- We've actually
used resveratrol, other sirtuin inhibitors, as well as PPAR
agonists in TIL expansion. So in the pre-rep expansion, while
you're-- And we just try to juice up the exhausted T cells to get them to turn over
a little bit better. And we can actually see that the clones, this
improves the ability of the terminally exhausted T cells that are in the
TILs to make a few more cell divisions.
And so then they become a bigger population in the pre-rep
product. So I think it's really cool and
red wine for everyone. Let's see how it goes.
Hi, my name is Catherine. I'm from Hopkins.
I have a question for Greg. So I know that Sue Keck
recently showed that when you knock out ACLY in T cells, that
also rescues a terminal exhaustion phenotype
and kind of biases back towards the progenitor
exhausted cell state. So I'm wondering
how much of your phenotype with the citrate transporter you think is
driven by
a lack of substrate for ACLY, and
if you can tease apart the effect of
having more cytosolic citrate versus more
cytosolic acetyl-CoA
in your model. And also, when you see more
protein acetylation, if that includes histones as well, and if you've looked at
the
specific histone modifications and how that localizes in the
genome.
Yeah. This is a great question, and this was our initial hypothesis.
That it was all citrate acetyl-CoA histones.
It turns out that the protein acetylation in the cytosol is
just as sexy. It's fun to study, and there's a lot of really interesting
biology going on with transcription factor acetylation as well as enzymatic
acetylation. That being said, we do see upregulation
of H3K9 acetylation and H3K27
acetylation, not in unique spaces. So that's the thing.
It's not differential. It's that the peaks are broader and higher when we do
CUT&Tag in-- So it's not that there's new enhancers
forming.
Yeah.
It's that the enhancers are
more enhanced, if you will. And we see the same phenotype when we divert carbon
with other manipulators.
Your question about ACLY is right on point.
If we use an ACLY inhibitor, we phenocopy citrate carrier
blockade.
But we are mitochondriacs. We just get really excited about how the
mitochondria are changing, and so we think this is of critical
importance. But we see the similar phenotypes of that delayed progression
to exhaustion. We see the same thing in clone 13, in
LCMV,
and they accumulate carbon, they accumulate lipids.
But that's a much more long-term system.
But
gun to my head, I think they'll probably still ultimately exhaust, but we are
slowing down that differentiation to exhaustion.
I have one more question. So,
I'm wondering if you have looked at the transition from naive to early
effectors,
or the transition from, I guess, memory precursors to
central memory cells. A lot of this biology, it seems like
everyone's focusing on kind of the axis between progenitor
and terminally exhausted cells, but I wonder how much of that biology
is also seen doing similar
things in those other cell lineage.
Yeah. It's a phenomenal question.
So the citrate carrier only gets upregulated with persistent stimulation, so we see
it for a short period of time in short-lived effector cells, probably because
they're so metabolically active, they've got to put carbon somewhere.
And so they're going to take in carbon from everywhere, and they need to make sure
it goes into multiple places, not just burnt up in the mitochondria and
producing a bunch of ROS. I'm guessing that's part of the biology here.
That being said, we have knocked out the gene and gone into Armstrong or gone into
vaccinia virus infection. We don't see a big phenotype in
memory formation or even the expansion into short-lived effector cells at day 11
post-infection. So time will tell.
It was pretty much a one and done experiment, but there could be
more there that's going on.
All right. Thank you.
All right. Last question. Thank you so much.
Hi, I'm Natalia Romero from Michelin Technologies.
I have a question about the composition of the media for the NK cells.
How much is concentration of glucose?
Yeah, that's my question,
too.
Yeah, I know.
I have to look it up. But yeah,
the glucose doesn't vary too much between the APO
and the regular
NK cell media. The biggest
differences are in the lipid composition and the presence of
insulin and ascorbic acid. These are the ones we're currently
investigating individually and in
combination. The glucose was pretty similar between the two.
Thanks.
All right. One last question.
Quick, about the continuous stimulation in vitro with the hypoxia, did you try
5% or only over 1%?
5% has no effect on our system. So we
chose 1.5 because that's the concentration of O2 that is able to
deposit pimodate
in vivo. So we figured that's the tried and true kind of hypoxia.
At first, I thought, "Oh, it's going to be this gradation.
As we get to 5%, something's going to happen." Nothing doing.
Everything's fine at
physiologic normoxia.
It looks basically like 20%.
Okay. Thanks.
All right. I'm going to go ahead and close the session.
Thank you everyone for such a great discussion and your continued interest in
immune metabolism, and we'll see you next year.